um he said that the hallmark of his
early strategy was to go for a lot of
fiance positions
uh and a lot of what he called i think
undefined upon structures which makes
perfect sense right
because what he was trying to exploit is
deep blue's
kind you know myopia you know it's sort
of
you know you can think of a computer of
that time it calculated very far but it
was still sort of short-sighted
in a certain sense um and the more
complexity you add to the pawn structure
the more the chance that the computer is
not able to perceive some sort of detail
way down a line way down the course of
variation
but not to belabor the point so bishop
g4 king's indian attack he goes b3
and already it's facing kasparov is
facing deep blue with the decision
uh bishop takes f3 is a move and that
does double white's pawns but it gives
white the two bishop advantage
and even now computers i think don't
very don't love to give up two bishop
advantage
um even though you know this is a
this is a decent line for black i've
played like this with white it's a very
unbalanced position which again plays
into what kasparov is trying to do
[Music]
so d blue goes knight d7 okay bishop
p2e6
it doesn't fall for the bait it doesn't
take on f3 because barb develops
and deep blue actually plays sort of a
slav system i don't know if d blue was
had book i don't think so but it might
have anyways
this isn't a very theoretical line it's
a double fiance ready
or king's indian attack bishop d6 you
can see deep blue making
all the correct slav moves h3 bishop h5
and e3 again
very restrained he's not playing for an
advantage
he's simply keeping the flexibility of
his position
so a move like e4 would have been more
conventional but it would have been a
little bit more defined
um i don't know if i'm making sense i
move like e3 and let's check the
reference to see what is actually the
most popular so e4
159 games e3 has only been played four
times including kasparov's game
five times um so it's an extremely rare
move it's not a particularly good one
but it does toss the ball back into deep
blue's core
but i think that one breakthrough deep
blue made and i don't know anything
about the programming i can only judge
by the chess
is that deep blue it didn't fall for any
of the bait it made a lot of these
healthy positional moves and it forced
kasparov to toss the ball right back
into kasparov's core
h6 um
h6 just improving its position creating
a hole for the bishop
the sparrow goes queenie one and on pins
himself
the blue responds with queen to a5
deploying the queen and preparing the
move bishop a3 now it is
it should be obvious to you that it is
very undesirable for white
to trade dark squared bishops that would
expose not only the holes in white's
position
such as you know b2 c3 but it would also
take the sting out of any potential king
side attack of which
you know the bishop could be considered
to be the general um
so how does white actually stop bishop
a3
um and this is a good good move to know
now there's two ways to do it a four and
a three and i think one of these moves
is clearly inferior than the other
positionally
i'll let you guys ponder that i'll be
right back
okay so um
so d blue had an opening database good
yeah so a3 is the move
and um the reason it is not a four
is because you weaken the b4 square
and and it's important to avoid this
whole complex of weaknesses a3 also
potentially prepares an expansion of b4
now deep blue goes bishop c7 which just
optically to me seems a little bit
mysterious i don't really know what it's
trying to do i think
one thing it might be trying to do is to
protect the queen
uh because without it uh there might be
some ideas of kasparov actually going 94
and trading off into an endgame the
lofty
um is it necessary to
you know can can you perhaps take the
foot off the sort of verbal gas pedal
and
you know not troll um and maybe just
listen and try to
i mean i like him but
we're really trying to delve deeply into
the position here
uh so 94 is a potential idea i don't
think it's a particularly strong idea
let's say black plays something like a6
knight e4 queen takes c1 knight f6
knight f6 rookie one but maybe
deep blue quantum clue didn't like the
possibility of
you know of this kind of expansion of
bishop c7 stops knight e4 because now
black simply has detached c4
uh queen takes a5 bishop takes a5 and uh
you've lost a piece and kasparov
continues with this very provocative
um strategy and it works
this time kasparov's provocative
strategy works it goes knight h4
and he provokes the blue right into
going g5
which it does and i'm not
i'm not using a computer i'm just going
by my own thoughts
this seems to me like a mistake um
and the reasons behind this are not
particularly difficult to establish
it creates so many weaknesses on the
king side i mean it weakens the diagonal
the knight on f6
i mean it it just it shatters the
fundamental
sanity the sort of soundness of black's
position
and this is one of the things that
kasparov thought the computer might
underestimate is the long-term weakness
of the king
which it did this is nothing in the
short term that's going to be mating i
mean white's pieces are still very
passive
but kasparov correctly judged that it
would prioritize space advantage
and it would prioritize the fact that
white has to move his knight back and
forth
and it would obviously de-emphasize
to its detriment the um
the sort of long-term uh attacking
potential that white has
i think it's from the first match so he
goes back and d blue continues to occupy
space with e5
to which kasparov finally you know goes
e4 and says enough is enough i'm going
to fix
the pawn structure in order for me to be
able to redirect my attention to the
king side rook f8 by d blue
and kasparov with another very
kg kind of move knight h2
now the reason behind this move is not
hard to establish you know the knight
from h2 has
several possibilities we've talked about
this in the last game right
you could go to a quote-unquote passive
square but it could be like flying into
frankfurt airport right
um the city that you're flying through
doesn't itself have to be a tourist
destination but you could be going to
see the freaking eiffel tower
the knight is going to see the eiffel
tower but you gotta fly for frankfurt
right
it might go to g4 it might go to f1 and
e3
uh but the fact that it sits on h2 right
now is not that important and i think
the gm's are very good at realizing this
by the way
and i know this can be a problem for a
lot of players because they look at the
temporary placement of a piece and they
conclude a move is bad because
the knight is on the rim but if you
place a piece on a bad square knowing
that it is temporary
you can actually get away with that um
it so this is the rematch then uh and
d blue goes queen b6 it starts to
flounder a little bit right it moves its
queen away
i guess it creates some sort of a pin it
stops f4 i guess f4 already was a threat
um that was the secondary idea of going
that h2
so for example if you go i suppose rook
88
and white can already go f4 and blast
open the king set and guess what you
know what black
black is regretting the move g5 so takes
takes takes
now the diagonal is open now white can
consider a move such as b4
x communicating the queen and then white
is ready to play queen h4 and basically
launch the decisive invasion
um so this was a very disquieting
scenario that
deep blue is trying to prevent and
kasparov goes queen c1
very interesting move um i think
kasparov is preparing
seeing the following moves um
a very very sort of um deep regrouping
of his pieces he's trying to activate
this d2 knight and lead it through f1 to
e3
in order to do that he has to place his
rook on e1 and then his knight to f1
and the reason he's able to get away
with all this is because the position is
very closed which is exactly what he was
aiming for
thinking that deep blue might
underestimate the space advantage
white overestimate uh rather its space
advantage and underestimate the
positional ideas
that would eventually lead it to pay
for its positional sins and tactical
sense
so a5 by d blue unconcerned continuing
to occupy space on the queen side
spar of launches is regrouping rookie
one d
blue continues uh to sort of bring
pieces to marginally better squares
the bishop from c7 goes to d6 where it
will then can
go to c5 combining with the queen
attacking f2 but this is not a scary
threat
sparrow simply continues with his
regrouping
and d blue sort of quote-unquote loses
his patience and it says
that's it it opens up the center
but the issue is that this is merely a
band-aid it does not in any way shape
form fix this
dreadful weakness of the f5 square
um and it you know normally when you
have weaknesses on one side of the board
you can try to open the center to
distract your opponent's attention but
because of the way the sparrow has
placed his pieces
in very solid fashion he's created no
targets um he can afford to continue
playing on the king side
despite the defile being open because
that is very difficult to exploit
well i might be making mistakes you know
for example i think white is already
better
i think g5 is a mistake but it might not
be like we'll check afterward with
stockfish and we will actually see if my
conclusions are correct
so d blue goes bishop c5 because sparrow
goes knight e3
and deep blue goes rook 88 so it's it's
can't he plug the f6 square by rerouting
the knight on the bishop what do you
what specific do you mean
what specifically what what moves like
bishop g6
is that sort of what you mean
um let's see bishop g6 move rook out and
we wrap the knight three eight
so uh there is what i call the three
move rule
which it basically states that if an
idea takes three moves or longer it is
unrealistic
um now that is a general rule of thumb
and i think it applies here so for
example if you were to go bishop g6
right
white has several ways that he himself
can improve his position i mean i think
that
you know okay maybe in
four we knew supposedly noob it's
if we could do what kasparov did during
the game
yeah knight g4 and then and then maybe
you can
sort of well you could even play knight
takes g4 right
and black has abandoned the pawn on h6
things start to collapse if you move the
king
now h4 can be played right and you see
how black's position on the king side
begins to crumble
so i think that this may have been
better marginally
the sparrow goes knight f1 uh this other
knight
is now being routed either to d2 or
after g4 to g3
and both knights then will be in a very
menacing fashion
staring at f5 so d blue says
well i need to stop this crop i i need
to do something it
in a sense senses the danger and plays
the move g4
and plays the move g4 uh trying i
suppose
to sort of change the dynamic of the
position
uh but again although it makes a lot of
noise it still
does not fix the weakness of the f5
square now kasparov has to be very
careful here
if he goes knight f5 uh d blue
has bishop takes f2 check now i would
still consider this with white like this
has to be calculated out
um because if bishop b1 then queen takes
h6 leads to i think inevitable checkmate
on g7
so i guess he was worried about
something else here maybe bishop g1
check
and then like gh
uh oh and if bishop takes h3 black is
check on f3
and then take on g2 and i'm going
quickly through this line
ah but this is not made because the
knight is defending that square so
but still i mean this does look
extremely menacing
and i suppose he was worried about that
and he decided to take on g4
now kasparov actually plays what i think
is a brilliant move
um and it is a move that that is very
tempting to play but
may look bad superficially because it
seems to play into black's hands
but the reality is that i think from my
initial
view of it it simply ends largely ends
black's counter play and the move is f3
now visually this may look
you know very very bad right it is
literally opening up this pin but
pins are only good in so far as they can
be exploited and they are temporary
kasparov is simply going to move his
king away on the next move
the knight is well defended and it the
pressure on the knight cannot be
reinforced
it can be taken but while there is no
longer a night to put on f5
you have to understand that advantages
are meant to be transformed
you know you can have one type of
advantage and then it can be transformed
into another
um and here the advantage of the knight
being
sort of axing f5 has been transformed
into sort of an attack against black's
king
then you could potentially have a bishop
come to f5
so this doesn't help deep blue goes
bishop b7 trying to patch the hole from
the other side of the board
rounding the bishop to g5 sparrow moves
his king away
so deep blue pins kasparov from the
other side and guess what kasparov does
again pins himself again
he unpins himself again um
instead of f3 what about knight takes g4
yeah so
had he got knight g4 d-blue would have
taken
and perhaps here it would have been
possible then to go knight e3
but perhaps kasparov was worried that
after something like bishop e6 this
knight
is kind of immobilized right because of
the threat of bishop takes f2 but i'm
sure that would have also been good
in these positions there's often
alternatives so kasparov just unpins
himself again he goes rookie two and he
says
okay i'm just gonna move my queen away
and
yet again the knight is going to be free
to go and yet again
uh there is going to be no way to
pressure white tonight further
before white does this so a4 by d blue
uh
coolly rebuffed by b4 of course
and now d blue launches sort of one
final attempt
to muddy the waters i think that it's
code detected
danger here right there's danger that
awaits
especially if kasparov moves the screen
away and puts an out of five the game
might be over in a matter of couple of
moves
now i think that deep blue's next two
moves are mistakes i think that
and we will check this on stock which i
don't think that white's advantager is
vast enough to warrant uh drastic
actions that quickly lost the blue the
game
but i do think that white's advantage is
still nonetheless very significant
and it goes five and it does exploit the
pin because knight takes f5 is not
possible
sparta takes to the pawn and it goes e4
very typical idea breakthrough
now of course the rook is also pinned
there's a lot of pins here if you take
with the pawn
you lose the rook not only do you lose
the rook now you lose the knight because
the knight has lost his defender
and this is sort of the calculation
stage this is what kasparov was so so
good at i mentioned this in the previous
game those of you who were here for the
analysis
of his game against sheriff esparov is
incredibly good at switching
from positional thinking to calculation
in a matter of an instant
one second it was very quiet position
the next it was crazy sharp
sparrow didn't make blunders in those
situations he simply adapted
to the new task that was set before him
and he
plays what i think is quite a brilliant
move a sacrifice
that eliminates black's main defender
and
tears apart the remaining a line of
defense between
white's pieces and black's king what
move did kasparov play in this position
wizard but i hope that my explanations
are at least partially helping you kind
of
somewhat appreciate it but i i get what
you're saying f4 indeed very nice you
guys are good you guys all deserve subs
um so the way it's gonna work is that
you are going to just kidding so f4 is
exactly right very nice
bishop takes c2fg and with the dark
squared bishop eliminated look at this
guy
remember what i said about it remember
when kasparov went a3
in order to stop it from being exchanged
well now he's reaping the rewards it's
operating uncontested look at black's
king
look at the pawns if you play hg i feel
like knight g4
perhaps even might be devastating
although here you can go e3 to try to
close the gate
ah i see oh this is brilliance
so you don't go knight g4 you do the
same thing but you do with tempo
what does kasparov do in the event of hg
amazing idea by gazparo
amazing idea by kasparov here
amazing idea i mean yeah horrible very
nice knight e5
attack the queen if you take the queen
boom
knight c4 should also do the trick i
think it's the same thing
um so this is why kasparov was
so freaking good i don't think there was
a difference but we'll check
d blue is 95 intercepting the bishop
sparrow goes g6
saving the pawn look at his passers now
bishop f3 d blue trying to sort of
you know it's trying to uh create some
sort of intrigue
yeah no i totally get a wizard and even
for me wizard it's very difficult to
appreciate the master i have to be fully
engaged
and i'm probably wrong on many cats so
bishop c3 by kasparov why does he do
this
um what is the function of this move
i think that he's just
trying to understand this move bishop c3
why didn't he do something like queenie
one immediately
um i suppose he is
uh perhaps insinuating some sort of
queen b2 in some cases
i guess but the thing is like you won't
do that immediately because the knight
on e3 is but i guess in some lines this
might be helpful so
deep blue queen b5 and kasparov goes
queen f1
and another very good move because barb
realizes that the end game
is in white's favor because now the
nature of white's advantage has
transformed
it is no longer a direct attack on
black's king but rather it is these
amazing past pawns protected um
protected i've never seen this game
before
but that's what when you
analyze a board game for 18 years you
develop the ability to do this
so the end game which deep blue has to
go for
is you know to my eye completely losing
because it's only a matter of time
before these pawns are set in motion
and black is completely paralyzed he
cannot move any of his pieces
that will allow the pawns to be set in
motion
um and so deep blue has nothing better
to do than to sort of bide his time it's
because power up slowly
but patiently prepares to push the pawns
bishop to h3
i appreciate it king f2 bringing the
king in and now
g4 exploiting the pin that de-blue has
just walked into
it may look like an impasse but i think
that kasparov had deeply
not done this it's almost zouzon perhaps
kasparov would have prepared g4 by going
rook g1
and then g4 uh but deep blue walks into
the pin
now if you take there's bishop g4 and of
course the end of this line that i
cannot take
king h6 rook g1 we have a mass trade on
g4 and finally these pawns are free to
roll supported as they are by the bishop
of the rook
six seven now the
transmitter of the moves decided that
further resistance was futile
deeply resigned because g8 queen is
being threatened as is
f7 the pawn on e4 is easily limited by
the king of the bishop
so that is how kasparov won the first
game in the rematch
um against dublo a very rich game now
let us check with stockfish and see
if indeed the several critical points
that we
uh sort of conceptualized
uh are indeed correct now here's the
thing
g5 first moment that we needed to check
with
mr stockfish move 13 g5
is actually one of the top moves
so it's not the top move but it is one
of the topics it keeps equality
according to stockfish
so i'm sort of going to superficially
see where the mistake was
so both sides playing well white
maintaining an edge
still equal g4 g4
is plus minus immediately h takes you
for
yeah that's good so it's saying that
after bishop g6
and wizard you were absolutely correct
baz with the sub that's what we're
talking about
black is fine and indeed that is the
correct idea to simply hold together the
f5 square
d blue kind of panicked too early and
here the advantage is not huge but it's
like
significance and this is correct
actually by d blue wow
deeply was really good so this is equal
according to stockfish
but it's it's like fluctuating so i
actually think maybe white is
ah queen takes f1 is a mistake actually
so believe it or not this position which
for a human
would be impossible to defend the move
h5
apparently allowed black to keep
equality and the reason
in the context of the game should become
simple right
you're preventing g4 you are preventing
g4 gary made some inaccuracies
and without g4 you will not be able to
clear the cobwebs so to speak
now there's a crazy line stockfish gives
that gives you a sense
of how insane
you know this whole business is um
f6 knight takes you i mean look at this
king have fearlessly giving up one of
the rooks
and now they fizzle out into a chaotic
end game which is equal according to
stockholm so
queen takes f1 actually was the decisive
mistake
um technically speaking so i don't think
we were necessarily wrong i think that
deep blue
set itself up for failure by weakening
that square
but it it missed these sort of
subtleties right it panicked too early
and then it
it didn't realize kasparov's long-term
idea this mistake makes perfect sense
because it didn't realize that kasparov
had this long-term plan
of pushing its pawns because it occurred
very deeply down the line
so in any case that is indeed
how gary kasparov went about beating
deep blue but you can see how close
these games are
and it took herculean effort by kasparov
[Music]
you